hey guys I'm Jess McDonald you're
watching GameSpot news it's the 13th of
March and I have nothing interesting to
say about that so let's keep going
first up Microsoft and Sony have had an
awful lot to say about each other and
themselves Microsoft began by saying
that they shouldn't have sugar-coated
the Xbox one controversy in reference to
the policy reversals Post III of last
year exec Phil Spencer said they could
have done a better job at handling the
messaging surrounding their console at
the time he said that since then he's
come to understand the importance of
being upfront with consumers even when
there's only bad news to deliver hopping
over to cerny it seems that we've
abandoned the console war piece and
resumed taking jabs at each other
Playstations Adam boys had a go at
Microsoft's launch parity policy for
games released through the company's
independent publishing program whilst
the program has drawn a share of praise
it's also attracted criticism as a
result of said launch parity which
requires games to launch on Xbox one the
same day as they do on other platforms
in what you'll either find hilarious or
caddy boys has tweeted in the interest
of transparency I want to share our
clause that lists which platforms you
cannot release on with this image
attached hilarious or underhanded let me
know what you think of this one in the
comments
Microsoft dnews doesn't stop there
though because bill Spencer has sort of
decided to kick the hornet's nest by
commenting on unhealthy xboxone fanboy
ism he said quite rightly that a natural
faction tends to be created around
whatever console you own with spawn
something of a dislike for those who own
the other console obviously not every
console gamer gets like this but we all
know of some who do Spencer said he
doesn't want Xbox fans to feel like they
can't be a fan of something else or that
they have to be an anti fan of another
brand and now some news to either make
you feel a lot better or a lot worse
about how you spend your time because
some dude has just hit 1 million Xbox
achievement points ray Cox spent 8 years
working on his gamer score and it was
the I like a challenge achievement in
titanfall that finally pushed him
/ the mark the moment was live-streamed
in case you wanted to check out the
replay Cox is the current world record
holder for highest legitimate game score
which either makes him super cool or
evokes concern depending on your
perspective let me know what your gamer
score is either in the comments or you
can do so on my Twitter and that's all
the stories I've got for you today but
be sure to join me again tomorrow for my
top 5 stories of the week I'll catch the
vents